bonjour today's video is kindly
sponsored by babble the world's number
one language learning gap hey 42 here on
the 22nd of august 1922
police were called to a disturbance at a
house in los angeles after neighbours
reported hearing gunshots
the lady of the house the wonderfully
named volberger oostereic
dolly to her friends screaming
hysterically
officers arrived to a grisly scene lying
in a slowly spreading pool of blood on
the living room floor was dolly's
husband fred oosterike a persistent
banging coming from the master bedroom
upstairs led the police to dolly herself
who'd been locked inside a large
wardrobe
once free of this unusual prison a
sobbing dolly explained what had
happened an armed stranger had broken
into the house demanding that she and
her husband hand over their valuables
fred had refused to comply and the
intruder had eloquently articulated his
unwillingness to discuss the matter
further by shooting fred three times at
play blank range
before bundling dolly into the wardrobe
a quick search of the house revealed
that fred's prized possession a diamond
encrusted watch had been stolen
from what i've told you so far this
probably sounds like a million other
robberies gone wrong that appear on the
news on a weekly basis
but there's more to this case than meets
the eye
like
a lot more and believe me you're really
going to struggle to guess who done it
in this one
despite her story dolly soon found
herself at the heart of a fledgling
murder investigation after all there
were no other suspects on hand and it
was well known that she and fred had a
volatile relationship several neighbours
claimed to have heard the couple arguing
on that night in question
it also appeared that fred had been
killed with a 0.25 caliber pistol
which was considered a ladies firearm
and not the kind of weapon you'd expect
an armed robber to favor
but whilst the police suspected dolly
may have been behind her husband's
murder
there was one major problem with their
case
if dolly had shot and killed fred
how had she ended up locked inside the
wardrobe
as it happens the police were right to
suspect dolly was hiding something
though it's safe to say that never in a
million years could they have guessed
what that something was
with over 10 million subscribers
worldwide and content updated daily
babble is top of the list for anyone
wanting to learn a new language and it's
easy to see why personally i want to
know my baguettes from my brioche my
mirror for my grandmere and my soleil
for my sworry
i want to be able to travel in france
and have at least a basic conversation
with the locals without scratching my
head in embarrassment
so i'm using babel to learn to speak
french babel is packed full of great
learning content and it's all designed
by real life language experts in order
to get you learning with real life
situations and dialogue it offers 10
minute lessons that are proven to get
you speaking in a new language in just
three weeks and did you know that babel
also has podcasts stories and games to
completely submerge yourself into the
language of your choice babble is great
because it works but don't just take my
word for it university studies have
actually shown that just 15 hours of
babble are equivalent to a full semester
of college spanish
so if you're looking to become bilingual
for professional or personal reasons or
you just feel like learning a new
language would be a great achievement
for you then i would highly recommend
giving babble a try
if you sign up to babble today you can
get 65 percent off that's less than five
dollars a month to learn a language so
don't miss out and click the link in the
description below our of warrior
bonchels
to understand how this murder came about
we need to take a look at the events
leading up to it because the seeds of
this crime were planted a good nine
years before it actually took place back
then fred and dolly had been living in
milwaukee where fred owned a successful
textiles factory
on the outside they had the perfect life
there was plenty of money they lived in
a nice house and with business at the
factory booming their future together
seemed bright
there was only one problem
fred usterike was beginning to suspect
he was losing his mind
he'd started to become forgetful
regularly misplacing things like clothes
and his favorite cigars
he was hearing things too scratching
scuffling sounds that seemed to come
from the roof
he'd have put the noises down to mice
only
dolly never seemed to hear them
fred went to see his physician and was
given the all-too-predictable diagnosis
that the stress of his high-profile job
was beginning to get to him the doctor
prescribed him some good old-fashioned r
r but fred had already discovered a far
better medicine alcohol
not that it helped in fact it only
seemed to make things worse fred began
to sense the sort of
presence
in his house he'd catch glimpses of
movement at the corners of his eyes
and once or twice he awoke in the night
swearing a ghostly figure had been
standing over him just moments before
fred lived with this growing paranoia
for five years before deciding enough
was enough it was time to move
preferably as far away from milwaukee as
possible
in 1918 fred and dolly relocated to l.a
fred probably hoped the sunshine would
chase away his demons
but sadly it wasn't to be
every single one of his symptoms
continued in their new home
something that seemed to confirm fred's
worst fears
it hadn't been the house
it was him
he was losing his grip on reality
fred descended further into drink and
his relationship with dolly deteriorated
rapidly
it wasn't helped by the fact he strongly
suspected his wife was being unfaithful
but in truth the tension between them
had been building for years
and
one night
the powder keg exploded
fred and dolly had a blazing growl both
were screaming and threats were made the
kind of threats that aren't easy to take
back the next day
but as it happened fred would never get
the chance because just when it seemed a
very dangerous line was about to be
crossed
a man burst into the room brandishing
two small pistols
there was a brief scuffle and in the
confusion the intruder shot fred at
point-blank range three times
before collecting whatever valuables he
could find
locking dolly in a wardrobe upstairs and
making his escape
if you've been paying attention you'll
know that matches the story dolly told
the police pretty much exactly
but there were two small differences
and they changed everything
first of all fred had distinctly heard
the intruder running downstairs before
entering the living room where he and
dolly were arguing
if this was a burglar in search of an
easy score
why did he run towards the homeowners
when he simply could have collected the
many valuables upstairs and left it his
leisure
even more interesting was the fact that
fred recognized a man who shot him his
name was otto sanhuber
he'd worked in fred's factory in
milwaukee as a sewing machine repairman
almost a decade earlier before quitting
his job suddenly in
1913. fred hadn't seen the man since
[Music]
so any ideas what the hell was going on
here
did dolly hire an old acquaintance to
bump off her husband
might she have been micro dosing fred
with poison to induce his fears of going
insane
or had she been telling the truth all
along and the whole thing was just one
really strange coincidence
actually
none of those things
the truth was far more bizarre
fred had been right to think dolly was
having an affair
her lover otto sanhuber had been hiding
upstairs at the time of the argument
and fearing for dolly's life he'd taken
her pistols from a draw in the
nightstand and rushed downstairs to her
aid there had been a scuffle and after
fred was dead otto and dolly quickly
cooked up the intruder story
otto then took fred's diamond watch to
make a robbery look more believable
before locking dolly in the wardrobe to
give her a cast iron alibi but
here's the thing
when i said otto sanhuber was hiding
upstairs
i didn't mean he just happened to be
there at the time of the argument
osso sun huber
was always hiding upstairs
fred had been living with the man who
would one day murder him for nine whole
years
without even knowing it
dolly had first taken a liking to osso
after seeing him working in fred's
factory in 1913
and keen to find an excuse to spend some
time alone with him she told fred that
their sewing machine was broken as
expected fred sent osso round to fix it
the very next day in what might have
been one of the earliest recorded
examples of a now rather famous adult
film trope
seventeen-year-old osso turned up at the
oysteric residence to find dolly dressed
in stockings a silk gown
and not a lot else
at first the affair carried on much like
any other whenever ratto could get time
off work he'd turn up at dolly's place
to
give her sewing machine an extremely
thorough fixing but the neighbors were
beginning to put two and two together
dolly knew otto couldn't keep coming to
the house without fred finding out about
the affair
and so
she came up with her plan she was going
to ask otto
to move in with her
that might seem like a logical step for
a woman about to leave her husband for
her bit on the side
but dolly had absolutely no intention of
divorcing fred
instead she planned to have otto move
into her attic in secret so that he
would always be on hand whenever her
sewing machine needed fixing
this unusual little scheme did come with
a few minor downsides from otto's
perspective of course namely that he
would have to give up his job his home
and all contact with the outside world i
can only assume dolly had one hell of a
nice sewing machine
because believe it or not
otto agreed from that moment on he lived
on his own in the oyster x's tiny attic
during the day he would emerge from his
lair to be with dolly
when his
skills weren't needed
otto kept busy doing the housework
fred would never know it but it wasn't
dolly who ironed his clothes made his
bed polished his shoes and cooked his
dinners
it was the man who'd been living in his
house for years without him knowing
and if that doesn't creep you out
nothing will
as utterly bizarre as this arrangement
was it went on like this for a
staggering nine years and remember fred
and dolly moved during that time thanks
to some very careful planning on dolly's
part otto managed to move with them
after fred's murder otto continued to
live in dolly's attic including yet
another house move
but his simple existence was about to
come to an abrupt end you see dolly
wasn't doing such a great job of playing
the grieving widow not least because
she'd started sleeping with the lawyer
who'd handled her dead husband's estate
a man named hermann shapiro and it seems
dolly was pretty fond of old hermann
because after they'd been seeing each
other for a few months she decided to
give him a gift a rather nice
diamond-encrusted watch
yeah
not her finest moment that it wasn't
long before the detectives investigating
fred's murder found out about dolly's
little gift and they immediately
connected it to fred's supposedly stolen
watch if they'd been suspicious before
now they were certain dolly had been
involved in her husband's murder
she was duly arrested and knowing she
might be facing a long spell in jail
her thoughts naturally turned to the big
man upstairs
otto
dolly worried her secret lover was going
to starve with nobody else to turn up
she asked her new boyfriend herman to
take a few supplies up to her attic
claiming she'd been letting her homeless
brother stay there for a while
it was a flimsy lie and when hermann
opened the trapdoor to otto's lair it
was exposed immediately
[Music]
remember by this time also hadn't spoken
to another other than dolly for 10 years
the idea that an actual human being
could come to visit him sent otto into
overdrive he thanked herman for the food
then promptly spilled the beans about
his affair with dolly fred's murder and
his role in the house which he described
as part-sex slave part-secret
housekeeper luckily ferroto not to
mention dolly herman didn't go to the
police he'd fallen for dolly pretty hard
and he had no intention of seeing her
end up in jail dolly would indeed escape
a prison sentence the judge threw out
the trial based on a lack of evidence
but when she got home hermann shapiro
made her an ultimatum
either the man in the attic had to go
or he would
and so after nearly a decade living in
secret in dolly's loft in 1923 otto
sanhuber was forced back out into the
world
over the following years the
investigation into fred's murder went
cold
but it was only a matter of time before
dolly slipped up again and in 1930 she
did exactly that when she
unceremoniously dumped herman shapiro
the one man alive aside from otto
sanhuber who knew all her most dangerous
secrets
annoyed at being cast aside herman
shapiro marched straight into the nevis
police station and told the first
officer he could find
everything he knew about his ex-partner
the man she'd kept hidden in the loft
for a decade and the crime they'd
committed together otto and dolly were
duly arrested and both were put on trial
for fred's murder
otto who since leaving dolly had managed
to get married to a woman who actually
let him live in her house confessed to
having killed fred but his lawyer
convinced a jury otto had only been
trying to protect dolly from her violent
husband
oso was convicted but of manslaughter
not murder and since the statute of
limitations had run out on that charge
he walked away from the trial a free man
somehow dolly also walked away without
punishment for her part in fred's murder
her trial ended with the jury unable to
reach a decision as to her guilt
as you can probably imagine the story of
the man who lived in his lover's attic
for almost a decade was a media
sensation otto was dubbed the batman of
la and the ghost in the garrett
but his story has been largely forgotten
in the years since though it did inspire
a truly terrible made for tv film
starring a young neil patrick harris
after the trials otto san huber faded
into obscurity and dolly oysteric
finally settled down living with her
second husband until she died in the
early 1960s so far as we know it was
just the two of them this time
this is such an unusual tale it's hard
to know what to make of it but if
there's one thing i'd like you to take
away from this video it's this
the next time you hear a strange
scuffling noise coming from jurassic
there's a good chance you don't have an
annoying mouse infestation after all
it's probably just the person who lives
in your house without you knowing about
it
you're welcome
and thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you